Narrator: Nazar is the owner
of The Restorer in Ukraine.
He specializes in repairing and restoring
furniture with damage and defects.
This is a wood-veneer
table with an oak base.
The owner forgot to blow out a candle,
and it burned through the veneered surface
into the wood.
This left a 30-centimeter-wide hole
that's about 3 to 4 millimeters deep.
Before he can start any restoration work,
he cleans and removes
as much of the burned area as possible.
He uses a small grinder
to remove the blackened layers.
Then he uses a blade
to carefully remove larger pieces.
After a basic cleaning and degreasing,
he adds clear packaging
tape over the entire area
and trims around it.
This leaves only the damaged area exposed
and the other areas protected by the tape.
Then it's time to repair the hole.
To do this, he's using a wood putty.
This acts as a filler and hardener
and can easily be covered
with toners, paints, and varnish,
which he'll use later on in the process.
After drying for about 40 minutes,
the putty hardens,
and he can sand it to
create a level surface.
He uses a cloth with a light solvent
to clean the dust off
before moving on to the next step.
After that, the tape comes off.
To start adding color back
into the repaired hole,
he uses a mix of tints and furniture wax
that he's color-matched
to the original wood tone.
He starts around the perimeter
and works his way into the center.
He's doing this using a nozzle
and gas soldering iron.
This melts the wax onto the damaged area.
The wax helps to restore
and fill the color
of the wood veneer.
He finishes this repair
by leveling the surface
with an abrasive restoration fiber.
Once the burns are removed
and the hole is filled,
it's time to add the wood grain.
Nazar does this by painting it
with a tinted alcohol-based toner.
He paints it in by hand
and uses a semi-matte varnish
to lock everything in
and keep it protected
from dirt and water in the future.